bonjour nicolas
bonjour magali bonjour heureuse de vous
retrouver à distance malheureusement
mais on va attendre que ce variant
omicron basse le pass vaccinale donc a
donc été a débattu en commission hier
que doit-on attendre de ces prochains
débats parlementaires à venir bachir
magali avant que le pass omikron
submerge concrètement moi j'ai pas
regardé un versant les débats jusqu'à 4
heures du matin trois heures et quelques
évidemment mais le texte il a été validé
pour pour l'assemblée le 3 janvier vous
l'avez vu et on peut noter deux choses
auch matin c'est que les socialistes
également tenu les républicains pour une
partie à la majorité ont voté pour
valider ce texte donc le dizet qui
passera le 3 janvier bien entendu à
l'assemblée et et on peut noter aussi
quelque chose parce que il y avait quand
même le conseil d'état il y avait pas
effectivement ce conseiller d'état qui
est venu voir ce texte et il a le
conseil d'état de quoi peut-on parler
vraiment j'ai envie de parler ce matin
de servilité du conseil d'état et ça
c'est très grave pourquoi parce que
rappelez-vous magali cas il était
question de la loi sur le pass sanitaire
c'est pas très vieux finalement vous
avez dit que ça se ferait pas ça se fait
le conseil d'état il avait dit qu il
avait conditionné le pass annie terre je
lis le texte à une mesure de protection
est pas à une obligation déguisée de
vaccinations voyez ça c'est très
compliqué parce qu'ils estiment ils
citent une atteinte disproportionnée à
la liberté d'aller et de venir au droit
du respect de la vie privée et familiale
et aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe
mais le conseil d'état il faut le lire
vous pouvez accéder à ces documents
c'est toujours très intéressant un souci
de les lire et bien finalement il faut
se poser quoi aujourd'hui comme question
il faut se poser la question de
l'existence du conseil d'état et de sa
légitimité puisqu'il est chargé un
moment donné d'être un moment donné
quand un contre pouvoir y en avoir et on
va le voir elle contre pouvoir ils sont
en train de tomber les uns après les
autres et c'est pour ça que c'est très
très grave donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer ils ont conseil d'état hier la
commission et le lundi 3 janvier dès
potron minet bien sûr sans passé ni
terre il va y avoir le texte à
l'assemblée donc on va se régaler parce
qu'on va voir on va voir quoi on va voir
combien y aura deux députés l'assemblée
nationale rappelez-vous sur le loi du
passé ni terre la premier article
deuxième article il n'y avait même pas
150 160 députés donc ça ça pose vraiment
des questions donc à une nouvelle
question il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions dans cette politique
c'est lens l'absentéisme probable ou pas
des députés alors certains avaient fait
le choix de la couardise premier vote
finalement loi passani terre pour éviter
bien entendu d'appuyer sur le buzzer
qu'ils ont face à eux le député à deux
boutons c'est assez simple comme
histoire et donc est là qu est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que c'est
absolument l'effondrement l'effondrement
de contrôle du pouvoir exécutif et ça
c'est très grave et dernière question
dernière répond cette question moi je
suis inquiet je vais vous le dire parce
que je lui ai d'ailleurs un très bon
article ce matin sur le site de rtl
france sur le député la reine de l'oise
pascal bois qui a son garage a été
incendiée et ça c'est très grave parce
que finalement on est en train de mettre
en place une hystérie une hystérisation
par le gouvernement jeu suite à une
discrimination officiers aujourd'hui les
non-vaccinés d'ailleurs géré à un terme
à notre cher ami de l'intérieur a
demandé des protections à l'ensemble des
diplômés préfet pardon pour les
parlementaires pendant la période du
vote vous voyez magali très sincèrement
je suis très très très inquiet pour
beaucoup de points et comment est ce que
vous jugez vous personnellement se passe
vaccinale que faire finalement le
gouvernement selon vous bah je vais je
vais prendre une phrase chère aux
libéraux je vais parler en
responsabilité moi ce que je pense très
sincèrement c'est que ce pass vaccinale
c'est un verrou vers l'enfer parce que
s'il saute se passe d'accidents parce
que s'il ya un an sur 20 dans le pacte
national pardon les libertés nos
libertés fondamentales
nos libertés publiques nos libertés
individuelles seront très très très
gravement compromise et finalement on le
voit on le voit c'est aujourd'hui un psy
vous une mesure absolument politique
inique que je considère moi il n'y qu'un
plus que sanitaire pourquoi mais parce
qu'on voit très bien qu'un échec sur la
page de la politique vaccinale pourquoi
pas parce qu'il ya une corrélation
énorme entre le nombre de contaminations
200000 faut-il le rappeler encore hier
soir et le nom de vacciner donc
finalement et on a ce truc incroyable
génial c'est à partir du 15 ou bientôt
même maintenant là il faudra avant de
donner pouvoir produire des cumuls c'est
très bien écoutez bien les cumuls
justificatifs en train pas de vaccinale
plus soft être négatif pour accéder à
certains lieux publics donc ça c'est
quand même bien la preuve que ça marche
pas des masses des masses trop étroit
point aussi pour le dire sur si on
regarde du côté l'étranger parce que le
gouvernement doit beaucoup bassiner
pardon de la rivalité avec les données à
l'étranger ce que faisait nos voisins
les îles britanniques et suédois kane
sur une aile natalité faible due au
micron première éléments ensuite vous
avez eue l'an ce moment l'arrêt de la
quatrième dose and israel ça c'est
extrêmement extrêmement important c'est
un article des échos notamment d'hyères
et vous avez aussi le ms qui a déjà
déclaré il ya quelques jours que l' arme
ultime l'art multi n'est pas les doses
de rappel pour lutter contre le coc vide
toutes ses formes ça c'est pour le côté
de l'étranger et pour le côté passe
vaccinale c'est ce qui m'inquiète
énormément ils s'inquiètent aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de français le pacte
d'actionnaires pour les enfants de 12 à
17 ans si c'est voter ça va être très
compliqué parce que ça aulas on est
vraiment dans une obligation de déguiser
il faut le dire quand même le contrôle
d'identité
mais c'est la faim de liberté de l'état
de droit et t8 berthet le déplacement et
vous aurez vous serez contrôlés par des
gens qui sont pas habilités à le faire
c'est un loupé j c'est un policier un
gendarme
donc moi j'aime beaucoup la prose de la
prose administrative on nous parle
maintenant d'une vérification a coûté
bien une vérification du concordance
documentaire là on touche au magic
ensuite la fin du secret médical à ce
fabuleux pas sanitaire vous ne pouviez
pas savoir si la personne en question
n'a même pas sanitaires ou impasse
vaccinale aujourd'hui un bac signale
vous dévoilerez à quiconque que votre
statut sérologique et ensuite la
discrimination grand v ne l'ont baptisé
avec le reniement de tous les libertés
fondamentales
donc finalement on considère la partie
des français si nous
sommes là proment devenait un côté
chasse aux sorcières et puis je finis là
dessus je finis la tue quid des
élections présidentielles ça aussi c'est
une grande question qui n'est pas trop
soulever gerra d'armes en avait parlé de
vengeance bourdin ya quelques mois du
vote à distance aujourd'hui on va
vitesse grand v peut-être vers quelque
chose ces élections présidentielles qui
ne s'est jamais vu et qui va
compromettre qui va compromettre
l'intégrité du vote à mon goût magali à
votre sens merci beaucoup nicolas pour
très vite au ce matin